es droht wieder einmal flughafen chaos
und das mitten zur sommerreisezeit jetzt
betrifft es vor allem easyjet passagiere
es wird enorme flugausfälle und
verspätungen geben denn die knapp 500
kabinenbeschäftigten streiken heute am
chaos flughafen ber das zur besten
sommerreisezeit zu den streiks hat die
gewerkschaft verdi aufgerufen der clara
maria becker ist für uns am ber
zugeschaltet klar wie viele flüge sind
in betroffene welche ziele wie ist die
situation ist gerade am flughafen
ja wir stehen hier auf dem platz vor dem
flughafen und hinter uns sieht man eben
die streikenden die immer noch verweilen
heute morgen um 5 uhr haben sie
angefangen zu streiken und der streik
geht noch bis heute um 10 bislang
mussten elf flüge gestrichen werden von
easyjet darunter waren flugziele nach
rom nach london nach amsterdam nach
kopenhagen also nicht nur beliebte
urlaubsziele sondern auch pendler städte
klar der br hat ja fast schon eine
peinliche chaos tradition kommt jetzt
eine weitere dazu wie geht der flughafen
damit um
ja wir haben gerade gesehen inzwischen
wurden die schalter von easyjet
automatisiert das heißt die leute können
dort ihr gepäck trotzdem aufgeben wenn
ihre flüge denn wirklich abheben also
geben sollten können ihr gepäck da
lassen können sich selber einchecken das
dauert natürlich viel länger also da
sind die schlangen jetzt schon bedeutend
länger geworden die leute haben
zeitdruck das ist natürlich extrem
nervig aber in erster linie ist
natürlich nervig für die leute die
eigentlich jetzt heute fliegen wollten
wir haben auch eine gruppe von frauen
getroffen die wollten zum beispiel
zusammen nach palma de mallorca fliegen
die wollten jetzt urlaub machen über's
wochenende und die kommen jetzt erst mal
hier nicht weg wir konnten auch mit
holger rößler sprechen erst der
verdi-verhandlungsführer und hat uns
einmal erklärt weshalb ist für sie
trotzdem wichtiger ist hier heute zu
strecken
na ja wir haben ja nun mal nicht so
viele mittel und ich kann ja nochmal
wiederholen wir haben über viele viele
monate verhandelt viele viele
verhandlungsrunden wir haben auch ganz
klar gesagt dass wir arbeitskampf
maßnahmen vorbereiten werden wenn
easyjet kein vernünftiges angebot gibt
aber das ist hat kein vernünftiges
angebot hatte mich überhaupt gar kein
angebot gegeben so wir haben die letzte
verhandlungsrunde am 16 mai gehabt und
bis heute bis zum 10 juli vier wochen
später gibt es kein neues angebot von
easyjet trotz klarer ansagen
unsererseits
natürlich wollen wir nicht die
passagiere treffen ist ja ganz klar
deswegen haben wir auch schon gestern
den warnstreik angekündigt in der
hoffnung dass sich viele darauf
vorbereiten können bzw dass sich das
unternehmen was ja dafür verantwortlich
ist die passagiere zu befördern auch um
die passage
ja wir haben es gehört also wurde
gestern extra vorzeitig angekündigt
trotzdem hat das viele menschen
natürlich nicht erreicht oder es gab
auch menschen die trotzdem hergekommen
sind zum flughafen in der hoffnung dass
sie noch wegkommen dass sie einen
ersatzflieger bekommen viele für viele
hat es nicht funktioniert und
die gewerkschaftler einem jahr haben wir
auch angekündigt ebenso lange kein
angebot auf dem tisch liegt wird auch
weiter gestreikt und das bedeutet
natürlich für easyjet passagiere
demnächst auch sie müssen sich auf
weitere dieser streiks und verspätungen
einrichten klara dubai hält die lage für
uns vor ort im blick vielen dank schon
mal und wir hoffen dann dass alle
menschen ja ihren urlaub trotzdem
antreten können dank klar